the world watched them grow up and now
it seems grow
apart a new book about the inner
workings of the royal family
is set to shine a light on claims of a
rift between princes william
and harry among the insights in battle
of brothers
is the claim that the queen viewed
prince harry and meghan markle as
erratic
and impulsive in the lead-up to their
exit from
royal life its author royal biographer
robert lacy
joins me now hello to you robert great
to see you
at this feud between the two brothers uh
the breakup of the
the fab four as they became uh known has
provided much
tabloid fodder over at recent years and
and months how real and how deep does it
go
i think it goes pretty deep and it goes
actually back to the years when you were
a royal correspondent but um
none of us knew about it in those days
you you you were in the
early years of the 20 at the 21st
century wasn't it you were
you were following and in those days the
boys were teenagers
um we didn't know then that um
the patterns that um we now see were
developing then that um
uh those were the teenage years when um
prince charles was intent on wooing and
wedding
camilla um he spent a lot of time away
from home
um high grove he they had this
extraordinary discotheque down in the
cellar called club h
don't know if you knew about it at the
time i certainly didn't but um
all sorts of things happened there well
nothing
nothing really improper but wild teenage
life
um harry was the the younger one two
years younger and a bit
than um than william um and he was
tied up in this fast set and of course
if you remember
you probably covered this he got into
trouble there was a drug scandal
um and then there was the the occasion
when he wore the the nazi uniform
um and um he came out of these incidents
as the villain um william who'd
you know gone with him to choose the
uniform went with him to the party
came out smelling like a rose because
that of course is how
we want us william is um
the golden hope of the monarchy we're
not quite sure what we make of a future
king charles the
third or queen camilla we know we love
the
idea of a future prince william um kate
such a marvelous couple um but um
inevitably harry had to play the the
role of the
spare to the air and it was interesting
things around though
hadn't he robert in terms of his
reputation he was hugely well regarded
for his military career
the work that he'd done uh with veterans
for example
and when he met and married meghan
markle there was a real hope that this
young couple could help the future of
the monarchy and modernizing
them and yet and yet it all went wrong
well let's hope he's not all gone wrong
let us hope that um
i think there are signs um that they
remain close they speak on the phone
um i think next year will be the the you
know the year of challenge
one of the advantages of course of harry
being a spare
in the years you're talking about look
at them there the two of them i mean
that's how we remember them that's how
we'd like to see them again
harry as despair was actually able to go
to war in afghanistan
in a way that um william couldn't the
british press
kept the vow of secrecy um you're right
you're talking about years which were
come back and in a way
megan was the the climax of the comeback
um
focusing um harry on all sorts of new
directions
but um you know they became in a way
too successful there they are getting
that that marriage
with the with with with the africa
afro-american preacher
um that that memorable sermon that
seemed to go on so long
he later talked about hearing the slaves
cheer him as he weds this couple
now there's a great dimension that megan
seemed to bring to the royal family a
mixed race recruit
such a tragedy that um that hasn't
worked work through and it's
it's it's one of the challenges for the
future for the monarchy i think
did she megan underestimate the power of
the institution that it wasn't willing
to bend and and on the other hand did it
underestimate
her that she wasn't willing to to be
forced to fit into its conventions
you you've got it you've obviously
stubbed studied the subject sarah
because
i i i i it is both sides so so many
people
take one side or the other say it's
megan was entirely
to blame um but as you say um
i i think with hindsight it's clear that
the palace when they saw
this um self-made successful woman a
celebrity in her own right before she
met harry a millionaires in her own
right before
she met harry um
she was some unlike any anyone had been
before in in the royal family
she has these dedicated um beliefs
uh feminism social change
there is there is the cutting edge um
her
her dedication to these causes of course
has clashed with
the royal tradition of uh impartiality
and um that's going to be one of the
challenges that's going to have to be
sorted out in the future
if the couple are going to come back in
some way into the family
and let's talk a little bit about that
that announcement that they were
stepping back
from royal duties they wanted this sort
of one foot in one foot out
kind of arrangement it led to the
sandringham
summit and you write about that moment
yes um and uh that was a moment of
of of family fury really because of the
way that
that harry had lost his temper and had
uh
released prematurely in the rest of the
family's view
his plans for moving abroad with megan
but
um william of course um also has
a temper when i started writing the book
people would say you know both brothers
um have
um you know can fly off the handle and
that's what happened
before the sandringham summit the queen
organized the so-called summit
um a meeting in the afternoon invited
the family to come
beforehand um to sort of try and
um rub off some of the rough edges
william actually refused he said he
would only sit down with his brother
um at the negotiating table with his
negotiating team
and that's that's something that's got
to
to change um in the future i think both
sides
have got to realize that to do what we
want i mean i
i i think we all would love to see them
back at this time of trouble
a government losing its way i mean let's
not make political judgments but
we have this wonderful british system we
have a government on one side to do the
work that we elect
we have this ancient hereditary
institution on the other side
to inspire us to set an example to use
an old-fashioned term
the queen did this brilliantly at the
beginning of of of the coronavirus
first spike her wonderful speech there
she was up on the side of piccadilly
circus
what's happening now all we've got is is
evidence of
of of disagreement and what is my hope
that next year
we may see a happier story um
and uh the two brothers coming back
towards each other in some way the queen
in that sandringham summit and the
statements issued afterwards
treading that line between the
grandmother and
the monarch how do you think she views
the behavior of prince harry and megan
and and increasingly now their new life
and the roles they're carving out for
themselves in the united states
well it's very difficult and delicate to
speculate about
you know the the thoughts and feelings
of the queen we know
that um she she loves harry
as a grandmother we know that back was
it uh
early march this year um she
deliberately invited harry for a private
sunday lunch
right in the middle of all the trouble
to to talk to him
to to tell him that anytime he wanted to
um come back um he would be very
welcome um she feels um and almost well
yes it's not
wrong as a sort of there's such a link
between
the queen who saw those boys through the
tragedy of their mother's
death um but she has a job to do
she's got um a royal family with
standards to
uphold and at that stage she didn't feel
that the commercial plans
that the sussexes were putting forward
um were dignified
were royal um so she said you can't call
yourself sussex roy sorry
if if if you want to create some sort of
company to make money
you'll have to call yourself something
else at that she she drew the line and
one can only sympathize with the queen's
plight and feelings torn as she is
between her love for this troubled boy
but also
um uh the consequences of um
the difficult upbringing that both he
and william had
robert lacy author of battle of brothers
thank you very much indeed fascinating
to talk to you
thank you sarah